Tom Clancy's novels read like action-packed movie scripts and many of them became just that,...
...as well as best-selling video games.
A former insurance salesman who never served in the military,...
...Clancy's first thriller, "The Hunt for Red October," was an instant success.
Its Cold War plot, like many of the books to follow,...
...pitted good guys, usually Americans, against their foes.
This thing could park a couple of hundred warheads on Washington.
Nobody would know a thing about it until it was all over.
Clancy's command of high-tech warfare and spycraft was so detailed,...
...that a Secretary of the US Navy once demanded to know who had leaked him classified information.
But Clancy said it was spooky to learn he'd made up things that turned out to be real.